nick is in atlanta hi nick welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave how you guys doing great man how
can we help
uh so right now i am in a situation
where
um i'm getting married in july for bless
my future fiance
yay and uh yep super super
excited for it uh it's awesome so um
she's great and we're really excited for
our future and i just have to say
uh you guys and your program is
something that i i love and it
gravitates
for me so well i love the the grind
mentality and long haul
and uh so right now we're on baby steps
too we're just paying off our debt
uh and we talked about attacking it
really between the three of
between two of us it's just my car my
student loans
her car and i just wanted to get your
your opinion
on if you think financially we're in a
good spot and we're attacking this the
right way
okay so how much debt do you have
uh so my student loans is 6500
which i plan on having done by the time
july comes through
i'll have my car on my car which is 16
thousand
and her car which is right now at eight
thousand
okay and what do you make uh
combined ninety well you're not combined
yet what do you make
uh fifty-four what's she well then she
makes 46 right
or 36. yeah okay yeah all right
um okay but you don't pay on each
other's dad
yeah and it sounds like when you get
married you're gonna have two car
payments with a ninety thousand dollar
income and that's going to be your first
order of business is to knock those out
do either one of you have big money in
savings
uh yes right now i've got forty five
thousand things
okay how much does she have saved
uh 15. and how much you all planning to
spend on this wedding
uh it's going to be about 15 but we're
getting some help from our
parents okay how much are you planning
on spending on the wedding how much is
your
fiance gonna spend not the parents
uh it's gonna be about five thousand
each out of pocket
you and her yes okay so you have 45
you're going to spend five on a wedding
she has
15 she's going to spend five on the
wedding mm-hmm did i get that right
mm-hmm okay the rest of it other than a
thousand dollars both of you are going
to write towards your debt today
she's going to put 10 on her car and
you're going to pay off your debt today
wait a minute that is that doesn't sound
real convincing
no i i want to do it i i guess the
scary thing of of bringing that down to
the baby step
one but well you're not you yeah you
won't
buddy you only got 22 000 in debt
right right no i know yeah it's it's
i don't know so you're gonna have you're
gonna have 15 000
laying around and she's gonna be at baby
step one
yep and then when you get married you're
gonna pay off her car
after you combine your accounts after
you get married nick you guys are going
to be ahead of the game now
what what you're having right now is
called cognitive dissonance
that that is your your brain is going i
hear dave and chris
but that's not what i was design i don't
this is new and you're right it is new
information
it is totally different way of thinking
because we want you to start that
marriage off without
having debt hanging on for 10 or 15
years buddy
it's going to pave the way for you guys
to start to really save up a fully
funded emergency fund if you're
unwilling to pay off your car today nick
you should sell it
well hold on he just heard it dave he's
okay it's new to him
he can do it nick you're going to do it
i believe in you well if you're going to
do
the reason that we teach what we teach
nick is it's the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth yeah and so you keep your set
your finances separate prior to marriage
and baby step one's a thousand dollars
anything above that
goes on all of your debts in your case
you're gonna do all that and you're
still gonna 15 000 left over
and you need five thousand set aside for
the wedding she needs five thousand set
aside for the wedding already did that
and uh then you're going to continue to
build your baby step three
until july into your fully funded
emergency fund
and she's gonna uh continue to pay down
aggressively on that car between now and
july
and if there's any car debt left and
there probably will be with her
after you get home from the honeymoon
i'm gonna knock it out you're gonna
write a check and be done with it and
then you're 100 debt free by the way
you're probably gonna have five or ten
thousand dollars left over after all
that happens
by july because you're a saver and you
make pretty good look
you take what he was paying on the car
the student loan of what she was paying
on the car
start saving that towards your fully
funded emergency fund
man you're gonna be there so fast to
some police and a young couple starting
off the right way
yeah that's boy nick play this call back
play it listen to it with her gain
agreement pinky swear
and start writing checks yeah yeah set
the five aside for the wedding
i'm not messing up the wedding no no no
not messing up the wedding but
you guys have done a good job saving
money and you've done a lousy job
managing your money
and so you know we got to decide now we
got to fix it that's right
it really is that's what it comes down
to so we know from studying millionaires
that the shortest path to being a
millionaire is
not keeping money in savings while you
have a car payment it's not on the list
of things that millionaires did though
it wasn't on the list of things they did
it's on the list middle class people do
it all the time
but not millionaires so it's just what
do you you know
what do you want to do how do you want
to win with money this is the dave
ramsey show